okay so after going to the comments for
ultimates - there was a lot of confusion
about the new state of the multiverse
and marble cosmic hierarchy and so on
and so forth and so what we're going to
do in this video is we are going to
clarify all that stuff we're going to
make sense of everything because it was
kind of tough to do because we were
covering a lot of things it was a lot of
stuff to digest and I kind of feel like
I wouldn't really be doing my due
diligence wouldn't really be fulfilling
the purpose of my channel if I just left
you guys hanging with all that
information but we are going to
basically run over the new origin of the
multiverse as well as the new Marvel
cosmic hierarchy now the easiest way to
do this is to go into a timeline is to
follow a chronological set of events
what we know is that in the beginning of
all things in existence very first thing
ever created there was just eight
universe and that was it we'd have no
idea what was in that universe we kind
of are left to assume that the Hulk
existed and spider-man and the x-men or
so on so forth but we don't know
marvel's never told us what was there
what we do know is that that first
universe came to an end for whatever
reason it's time ran out whatever the
case may be we have no idea but the
first universe was replaced with the
second universe second universe came to
an end the third universe replaced the
second universe and so on and so forth
until we got to the sixth universe this
fixed universe is the universe that
Galactus originates from that universe
basically had a space explorer named
Galan and for reasons that we don't need
to get into that universe is basically
coming to an end and Galan was trying to
find a way to stop it ultimately he
wasn't and so in response the sum total
of all life in existence in that
universe merged with Galan and he was
born into the next iteration of the
universe as Galactus now this is where
things changed or previously it was just
a singular universe universe one two
three four five and six when the seventh
universe was born it also gave birth to
the multiverse and this multiverse is
just an infinite number of universes now
it's time progressed and of course you
know as we know yet Galactus the
Incredible Hulk Bruce Banner you had
spider-man so on and so forth we know by
virtue of the events of secret wars that
the multiverse came to an end and
all-new all-different marvel came out of
that
that's the chronological events of
things as they unfolded now there's a
lot more to it than that I mean there's
all different kinds of groups and so on
but for the sake of keeping this easy to
understand that's basically it now in
terms of like the cosmic entities if you
were to look at your hand
imagine for example that your thumb is a
universe and your index finger is a
universe and your middle finger is a
universe and your ring finger and your
pinky those are all universes each one
of those universes has its own set of
cosmic entities your thumb has its own
version of eternity your middle finger
your ring finger your pinky finger they
have their own versions of eternity they
have their own versions of infinity they
have their own versions of whatever
other cosmic entities may exist out
there Galactus the Celestials so on and
so forth that is essentially how those
cosmic entities work in terms of a
hierarchy the top two are eternity and
infinity and again I have four videos
that run over the entire Marvel cosmic
hierarchy the way that it used to be so
we don't need to go super in-depth into
that but in terms of the multiverse in
this form and function above everything
you have the one above all hence the
name the one above all now there are two
one of our balls in Marvel Comics you
have the one above all who's the Supreme
Being and then you have the one above
all who's a celestial we don't care
about the celestial you can just kind of
ignore it but the fact remains that
after the one above all you have the
Living Tribunal now people's
understanding of the Living Tribunal
it's actually wrong in a lot of
different ways a lot of people look at
the Living Tribunal and they say okay
this is like the supreme judge of the
Marvel Universe any judges everything in
the multiverse that's it he just sits
around and make sure there's no
imbalance whatever that means or
something like that that's actually
incorrect the Living Tribunal is a judge
and he is there to make sure that
there's no imbalance but the imbalance
strictly for teams to magical energy so
let's say for example that there is a
universe where the Silver Surfer kills
Galactus becomes Galactus absorbs all of
this energy and then just goes around
the universe wiping everything out The
Living Tribunal will not step in because
the Silver Surfer is not using magic
he's using the power of the universe
itself let's say that if we were to grab
the Thanos imperative story where do
your original Captain Marvel decree was
dying he handled all the energy of the
superheroes and killed mistress death
and so the universe basically unfolded
with nobody being able to die it just
filled with life and then eventually
spilled over into the main Marvel
Universe the reason why the Living
Tribunal did not step in is because no
magical energy was used in that scenario
but if we had a universe where Doctor
Strange were to absorb all magical
energy in that universe taking it away
from you know
whistling if you ran up on the Scarlet
Witch stripped her of her magical energy
and absorbed it if he went to every
single magic wielder took all their
magic absorbed it into himself and
became omnipotent The Living Tribunal
would step in because that is an
imbalance of magical energy no one has
enough magic to stop dr. strange that is
when the Living Tribunal would begin to
act this is the reason why and the
Infinity Gauntlet story The Living
Tribunal did not intervene and stop
Thanos from using the Infinity Gotham
because the infinity gems are not
magical artifacts they are artifacts
that allow people to manipulate whatever
aspect of the universe that infinity
stone is tied to so a person who can
Neos in possession of the reality stone
can manipulate reality person who's in
possession of the space stone can travel
from one place to another
instantaneously by folding space in on
itself whoever it is is in possession of
the time stone to manipulate time
someone and so forth now there are other
multiversal concepts in the realm of
Marvel Comics you know the time variant
authority and omniversal development
court and so on and so forth we don't
really need to worry about that those
are really like the top two guys now the
information that I just gave you is
spread over probably some one or two
hundred comic books
spanning not alone maybe 30 years or
something like that it's really just
kind of grabbed from bits and pieces of
different stories over the course of
marvel's publication history the beauty
of Ultimates 2 is that not only does it
basically change everything and make it
more streamlined but it gives it to us
in a singular location what ultimate
stew did is it said this in the
beginning there was only one universe
and this universe was called
the first permanent now who it was it
made this universe we don't know we're
just kind of left to assume that it was
the one above all but regardless of who
made it the universe was sentient
meaning the universe could think for
itself that had feelings and emotions
and so on and so forth the universe
desired to create life and it did but it
only created life in one form this form
was called the Celestials now the
Celestials themselves created life on
their own they created galaxies they
created stars they created solar systems
and planets and different races you know
humanity and so on and so forth created
all different manner of life
some of the Celestials approached the
first universe and said are you happy
with what we've done other Celestials
did not those Celestials who approached
the first universe in
sought approval we're considered to be
faithful those Celestials who did not
were considered to be not faithful
the faithful Celestials were called
aspirants the non faithful Celestials
were just called Celestials but what
this did is it basically led to what
amounted to a holy war to a religious
war of sorts in the sense that it was a
war between the aspirants who were
faithful to the first universe and the
Celestials who were not now the reason
why this war is so significant is
because it would be like if you had a
war between 1 million different versions
of Galactus all with the same power all
fighting each other it would literally
just destroy the universe and that's
exactly what happened if the first
universe were a piece of glass it would
be like if you threw the glass on the
ground it would just shatter all the
pieces now following this war the first
universe its soul basically its
consciousness grab the aspirins and took
off outside all space and time leaving
behind only the Celestials so going back
to the example of your hand if we were
to say that one of the shards of this
broken universe was your thumb and
another shard was your finger your your
pointer finger another shard was your
middle finger and another was your ring
and your pinky finger then the
Celestials who were left behind all
retreated to different locations so some
of the Celestials went to your thumb
some of the Celestials went to your
index finger some of the Celestials went
to your middle finger and some went to
your ring finger and your pinky finger
in addition to this each one of these
fingers each one of these chars became
its own universe and that's how the
multiverse came into existence now each
of the multiverse is reach of these
universes began to evolve and grow on
its own and they each developed their
own cosmic entity so again given this
whole change that the ocean is did your
thumb still develop its own eternity
your index fingers still developed its
own eternity your middle finger your
ring finger and your pinky finger each
developed their own eternity but in
addition to this you also ended up
having all of your fingers representing
a singular eternity a multiversal
eternity if that makes any sense
basically the physical form of the
multiverse oh if the multiverse could
get up and walk around that would be the
multiversal eternity the other big
change here that al Ewing made was the
marble cosmic hierarchy previously it
was believed with a Living Tribunal that
because of living tribunals served the
purpose of basically making sure that
there was no imbalance of
magical energy that the leading tribunal
had to be powerful enough to overcome
any being who gathered all magic in
existence and so if for example going
back to our reference of dr. strange if
dr. strange had not only taken all the
magic from all the magic wielders in his
own universe but then traveled around
the multiverse in all the dimensions and
absorb all the magical energy in
existence the Living Tribunal still had
to be powerful enough to be able to take
him out that was the previous school of
thought what the ultimate said is no
that's not the case the power of the
Living Tribunal is relative to the age
of the multiverse and so that's the
reason why the Living Tribunal before
all-new all-different marvel is more
powerful than the Living Tribunal after
all-new all-different marvel because the
multiverse as it existed before all-new
all-different marvel had been around for
billions and billions and billions and
billions and billions of years and so
the Living Tribunal had untold amount of
time to develop its power and for its
power to expand and all-new
all-different marvel the multiverse is
basically brand-new if the Living
Tribunal was a person it would be an
infant its power is miniscule compared
to the power that it had before all-new
all-different marvel and so what this
meant was that in relation to the other
cosmic entities the Living Tribunal was
equal he simply was just a judge it was
really more of like the position he
holds that they had respect more so than
the power that he had and so because of
that master order and Lord chaos them
killing the Living Tribunal would be
like them killing any other cosmic
entity
he was basically just not nearly as
powerful as he was that's the reason why
when you saw his character drawn out in
ultimate he was small he wasn't huge he
was a small guy that's one of the things
you have to remember is whenever you saw
The Living Tribunal before all-new
all-different marvel he was always
depicted is massive in scale the way
that he's drawn in Ultimates is designed
to reflect the little power that he has
he's not as powerful as he was before
all-new all-different marvel so he's not
as big as he was before all-new
all-different model now in truth I doubt
his size has anything to do with his
actual power but it's just a way for us
to be able to physically see how much
power is in relation to how he is now
but nonetheless those are really kind of
like the big changes that were made in
ultimate in terms of the Marvel cosmic
hierarchy for each individual universe
the hierarchy is still relatively the
same you still have your own eternity
you still have your own thing going on
so on and so forth but in terms of power
scales things are all kind of jumbled
and so there is no definitive cosmic
hierarchy at the moment because it's all
still being worked out we're still
learning who the most powerful cosmic
entities are it's basically just kind of
like the Wild West and no-man's land so
it could be that some new cosmic entity
pops up that no one's ever seen before
who's some new creation and is more
powerful than everybody else including
the Living Tribunal we have no idea at
this point we just kind of have to read
the stories and wait and see what they
say in order to come to a conclusion on
what the new Marvel cosmic hierarchy is
but with that being said guys we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
it's explained make sure you guys have
the sub button to become part of the
robb cork you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I'll
catch you all later peace
[Music]